on va faire l'interview fin de phrase
donc ça commence avec vous on fred je
vous dis le début de la phrase vous
dites la fin si je n'avais pas rencontré
omar et bien je serai décédé omar fred
est tellement drôle que que je ris tout
le temps ça c'est vrai j'aimerais en
faire plus et donner de l'air sir fred
je ne sais pas si je dois le dire ou non
mais omar pierre qui roule n'amasse pas
mousse s'appelle omar
ce que j'aime chez le pen c'est sais
rien il y avait senti bien la seule
chose qui me ferait aimer les hommes
c'est que vous marrer la peau -12 que
les autres sommes effectivement un noir
et un blanc ensemble ça ça déménage tous
les deux on a un truc en commun c'est
qu'on déteste ce gros con de de michel
vosgien non directeur de la socotec
oui c'est vrai
tout cela n'est pas la forme d'une
souris voilà non en revanche on est fan
de pascal obispo chéri laisse nous te
dire une fois pour toutes que faisons
l'amour
nous dire adieu si je regarde l'émission
franchement en maintenant on peut dire
que canal c koi canal thierry cette
incroyable depuis la dernière fois est
ce que tu as beau si si on devait se
souvenir d'une vanne à nous ça serait ce
serait un homme persuadé que sa femme le
trompe rentrer chez lui il dit à sa
femme chérie je sais tout un bon tu suis
en quelle année il est mort napoléon je
peux la refaire avec une autre vol ça
serait ces deux mecs qui sont dans un
mariage et s'approche du buffet et lundi
à l'autre jean pierre je te refaire du
vin oui merci mais moi c'est yves cela
est passé on va viendre à la gare à
celle là dans les publics dans les
belles années de canal dans les bureaux
y avait beaucoup de pierre lescure et
d'alain de greef vous appeler ça comme
ça
oui chérie tu es vraiment un un homme
dommage ils venus de la base et toi tu y
vas fin d'accord d'accord ce qui est
bien chez ben laden ce qui nous a fait
préférer le train
bien sûr avec ben laden c'est possible
si jamais ça s'arrête demain ça sera
cause de toi
le jour le plus heureux de ma vie
ça fait dix ans que dure le vrai
problème du foulard à l'école c'est
surtout pour la piscine sinon c'est bien
depuis que je suis connue c'est plus
facile pour les autographes et joliment
demande d'abord il n'en avait rien à
[ __ ] j'avais volé distribués dans la
rue
kruyt star flyer pour le soir et rails
ça c'est cool il ne faut pas vendre la
peau de l'ours
surtout si l'on sait des dents encore le
biberon bbc al pacino qui me la piquer
dans scarface simple nom sera j'étais
taillé sur mesure pour moi non mais
finalement nous dans la vie ce que je
sais faire le mieux c'est c'est pas moi
qu'il faut demander ça mon ex ça va je
me racontais de temps en temps qu'est ce
qu'il ya tu vas me lequel sony aura
coûté je me racontes là parce que je
préfère chez charles de gaulle c'est son
aéroport ça c'est sûr
quand je regarde la télé quand je
regarde la télé moi aussi maintenant
j'ai peur des arabes à râches que je
peux dire est ce que je préfère chez
dieudonné
ce que je préfère chez dieudonné
sa rapidité d'esprit non mais c'est vrai
parce que là c'est tellement c'est petit
flip maintenant tu parles est devenu
c'est extraordinaire alors que c'est
disproportionné ce qui lui arrive je
trouve vraiment même s'il n'était pas
très drôle le jour de france 2 chez
marc-olivier fogiel de rendez hommage
ouais il me rendait hommage donc j'ai
dans une situation délicate mais c'est
vrai que j'ai été jouée à liège la n'y a
pas très longtemps et là bas aussi il a
été interdit donc je trouve vraiment que
ça prend des proportions incroyables je
peux vous le dire et je le signe je
donnais n'est pas antisémite
il faut qu'il ravale et qui s'excuse
dans ce qu'elle a fallu s'excuser et on
leur pardonnera s'il s'excuse
franchement il faut il faut sinon ça
s'est excusé serravalle ce qu'ont à dire
les anges et dj s'excuse je voudrais
dire qu'il est qu'il est qu'il ait
antisémite ans dans tout ça veut dire
que malheureusement peut-être que il a
fait une gaffe voilà il haïssait mais
c'est parce qu'il sait pas ce que c'est
parce qu'il dit là ils n'ont mélodies
dis pas ce que je lui au téléphone il
m'a dit j'ai été maladroit ce n'est pas
que oui alors moi c'est oui alors dans
ce cas là vous êtes arrêt dû être un
moment il m'a appelé
donc je le début
enfin d'accord vas-y le plus dur quand
on monte un one man show s'est fait rare
10 font tous les matins quand je me
réveille tous les matins quand je me
réveille je me lève et je te bouscule et
tué la veille par un peu comme
d'habitude mais avant de monter sur
scène je suis souvent en coulisses on
peut rire de tout sauf on peut rire de
tous sauf si c'est pas marrant si un
jour j'ai un fils je l'appellerai si un
jour j'ai un fils ou une fille je
l'appellerai
une fois par an j'ai bien ce que je
préfère chez moi c'est ce que je préfère
chez moi c'est mon canapé la dernière
fois que j'ai pris de la coke
mais enfin que j'ai pris de la coke ne
m'en souviens pas très bien parce que je
devais être sous acide je ne sais pas si
je dois le dire ou non pas si je dois
qui dira ou non alors je crois que je
vais pas le dire
ce que j'aime chez les antisémites
sérieusement voilà un truc que j'aime
bien avec les antisémites moi j'aime
bien parler avec les antisémites
vraiment j'adore ça parce que quand je
parlais avec des juifs j'entends que des
problèmes c'est les problèmes qu'on a en
france et les problèmes avec les
mariages mixtes les problèmes avec les
guerres israélo-arabes les problèmes
d'accord je parle avec des antisémites
j'entends que des bonnes nouvelles c'est
les juifs qui ont tout l'argent c'est le
judo
rien lire on va faire le test ultime
pour savoir si on peut vraiment plus
rien dire on va faire une interview fin
de phrase
[Musique]
d'accord je dis pas qu'il ya des [ __ ]
des drogués à la télé jeudi que magic ya
deux ans il ya des gens il ya des gens
différents
pascal sevran et sa trace en partie par
exemple nouveaux corps ce qui est bien
quand et pdc
bah c'est que t'as pas besoin de divorce
est encore fécond savent tenir là je
rêve d'une france nettoyer deux des
journalistes qui me posent des questions
de combat mais vraiment c'est celle de
nicolas sarkozy a raison il faut
absolument faire parler de soi
il ne faut pas jeter la pierre au
pédophile car tu pourrais blessé
l'enfant qui porte dans les grâces
tu vois tirer un handicapé s'est
toujours fait un mec qu'a pas de chance
comment il ya plein de place pour les
handicapés de stationnement on interdit
la voiture en ville
je souffre pour la parité hommes femmes
bien sûr sauf si sauf si laurent baffie
remplacé par christine boutin
la phrase qu'il ne faut surtout pas dire
en ce moment c'est on peut pas plaire à
tout le monde
j'aime bien voir des flics dans la rue
parce que ils sont pas dans le bistrot
le vrai problème avec les juifs
aujourd'hui c'est il n'y a pas de
problème on dit que les arabes sont
voleurs c'est faux il en apprend tous
les musulmans ne sont pas des
terroristes mais l'embellie les petites
musulmane c'est des petites bombes la
qualité qu'on pourra jamais enlever un
islamiste c'est cédant maires des
bouches
ça sera bien
ce qui m'énerve chez les catholiques
c'est ça c'est qu'ils élisent des papes
un peu trop un peu trop black et surtout
trop jeune les inconnues sont mais qu'on
met tout le monde en parle voilà
exactement alors bernard tapie comme
vous êtes le roi de la tchatche vous
allez finir mes phrases je vous donne
mes débuts comme donner enfin en ce
moment je sais pas ce que j'aimais ça se
présente pas mal c'est bien un truc que
je sais pas faire c'est faire semblant
la seule différence entre le théâtre et
la politique c'est quand on tue au
théâtre c'est pour faire rire ce qui
manque à chirac par rapport à mitterrand
c'est jacques séguéla le seul truc que
j'ai jamais pu m'offrir avec l'argent
c'est le crédit lyonnais
je me serai remboursé plus tôt
pas pouvoir est en général j'ai plus aux
femmes qui ont le goût du risque
c'est vrai au moins oui franchement
maintenant je peux te le dire les
missions que je faisais sur tf1 je
regrette de l'avoir arrêté
allez allez comme ça une bonne tête mais
montre en or je tirais l'âge pour pour
t'apprendre que tu fais pas la
différence entre l'a6 et laurens et
avait des prêts des barrois en quoi on
en a chié pour nom mais il a été sympa
avec moi parce qu'un jour j'ai gardé ça
et je vais garder un on est on faisait
les missions sur canal juste devant
gildas la juste avant que j'y aille vie
j'ai un truc pour toi tu le regardes ça
quand tu seras parti allait me faire une
carte ma poche et quand je sors je
regarde ce que c'est c'était car du
monopoly vous êtes libéré de prison
assez bien
serra capitaine se glisse sermeq son
micro en direct à la télévision
thierry cette incroyable depuis la
dernière fois ce que tu as tu sens plus
heureux mais il n'y a même pas de
comparaison c'est le voir quitter sa
sénégalité ses ventes se sont vraiment
porte bien le deuil je sens que ça y est
quoi voilà le jour mais 60 ans je me
suis dit tout marche à et tout marche
ah ouais t'as besoin de viagra du cialis
1 c'est là dedans le banc fin est
franchement si tu avais été au ballon on
appela je suis sûr que tu en es boîte et
alors ça aurait été plus normal ça
aurait fait plus normal merde
le combat le plus dur que j'ai eu à
mener c'est une chanson de brassens qui
disent les gens n'aiment pas que l'on
suive pas le même chemin que ouais c'est
un peu ce conte relaxe était de très
mauvaise réputation
voilà c'est ce qu'ils veulent pas qu'on
soit différent quoi c'est qu'ils sont
nombreux aujourd'hui ce qui me rend le
plus fier c'est mes enfants les cadres
c'est marrant malgré tout ce que j'ai
vécu je continue à croire que qu'il faut
toujours y croire
des fois je me dis si seulement j'avais
pas alors ça je me le dis jamais jamais
jamais pas une fois je me suis dit ah si
j'avais su mais c'est ce que j'aime dans
la vie j'ai pas de rétroviseur mais par
contre je garde c'est ce qui fait que je
garde jamais de mauvais souvenirs des
gens qui m'ont fait chier je promets à
celui qui me traitent encore d'en
admettre un pas sur sont des souvenirs
d'un truc chez moi j'aimerais que ce
soit j'ai fait une des écoles pour les
jeunes qui étaient sans boulot ouais et
on à la sortie près de 10000 sans rien
demander à personne et il y en a près de
10000 dans la nature très curieux belle
carrière à sam
parmi tous les salopards qui m'ont trahi
je n'oublierai jamais bien que mes potes
n'étaient pas dans le lot interview fan
phrase
alors christophe je vous donnais début
de phrase si vous avez déterminé par
exemple rires c'est un bon moyen de 2
poser les bonnes questions je dois tout
à à la méthode ogino la religion c 'est
une vaste rumeurs persistantes depuis
que je suis connue c'est plus facile
c'est plus facile de c'est plus facile
de téléphoner au volant
ouais j'ai grandi entouré de entouré de
parfum et d'amour la nature mais bien
gâtés au niveau de niveau leur haut
niveau de la séance alors tu veux dire
pour 2006 j'ai décidé d'arrêter de utile
et d'arrêter d'arrêter si l'alcool me
gêne dans le travail à temps laisse la
finir cette vanne à la can en profitent
bien parce qu'elle croit qu'on est en
2005 encore un
c'était la drass a fini je vois pas ce
que moi j'ai un amour absurde c'est
comme ça là c'est l'alcool me gêne dans
le travail j'arrête immédiatement
travail
alors n'en sommes pas là mais dans un
mois ça fait vers la mecque
moi j'y crois moi pour me détendre je
fais beaucoup de de sport je lis
l'équipe
allez la france c'est le pays
la première manche et la précédente
d'aller à la pataterie de rien sur la
proche la france et des pays de 2,2 de
voltaire rousseau hugo et
malheureusement sarkozy là tu vas pas de
faire un copain je sais qu'arnaud et
jette pas l'ump est renommé vous quand
même vous avez pour sarkozy je trouve
qu'il s'attaque à de vrais problèmes et
propose de vraies solutions et pas
simplement de mettre les choses sous le
tapis en attendant que ça passe
bon et puis lâche mérite là et on peut
pas lui ôter je pense pile-poil inverse
qu'il aime beaucoup mais on peut pas les
attend il a raison pas dire qu'ils
mettre les problèmes sous le tapis c'est
vrai mais pas de problème qui est posé
les bonnes questions il a les mauvaises
réponses pas exactement la bilan qui est
du vent du début à la fin la fin ce mec
est un courant d'air et je pense qu'en
plus il est il est parfaitement
dangereux
alors on continue vous finissez mes
phrases 1 je suis fan de 2
non je suis fan de dodo pèrsone poteau
aznavour potter oui moi aussi j'adore ça
nous fait encore sarkozy
tu vas prendre l'ascenseur je pourrais
me reconvertir dans dans peut-être dans
la politique
si j'étais dieu je ferais je fais mon
dieu si j'ai je ferais je ferai quelque
chose pour que que mon fils ne meurt pas
dans ses souffrances atroces enfin
j'aurai au moins vacciner contre le
tétanos ou la seule fois où je me suis
fait [ __ ] c'est ben c'est sans doute
la première fois où j'ai tourné le dos à
mon banquier
alors attention la force de laurent
ruquier c'est à ces de m'avoir engagé
non je pense le rock et c'est vraiment
d'être sympa avec je crois tout le tout
le monde et de dd c'est tout l'intérêt
de se faire ou se faire contredire
violemment
donc
2 le côté écouter aussi voilà ce qui est
impressionnant chez stv c'est ça c'est
sa mère c'est sa mère l'en je dis
sérieusement à sa mère que j'ai
rencontrés qui est une femme adore à
bord ah ouais mais lui aussi
lui aussi d'ailleurs gré la plus grande
erreur de ma vie c'est la grand-mère de
signer peut-être une volée j'aimerais
bien avoir une plus grosse ou plus
grosse grosse mais ne tiendrait pas dans
l'ascenseur thierry tu m'excite quand tu
alors tu m'excite tu sais que quand
c'est quand tu lui poses des questions
que cette écoute les t'écoute les
réponses c'est souvent tu fais
techcite harbaoui c
bon
alors bouder rires c'est un bon moyen de
communication oui je dois tout à dieu
j'ai grandi entouré de entouré des
cafards continue non non non j'ai un
carré d'as la première fois il s'en
tirer tout lé entre benfica et son
ballon mais ce genre de cafard quand on
leur mettait du bégo aisés comme ça tu
peux mon métier la nature m'a bien gâtés
au niveau 2 de mon nez oui j'ai un
bonnet c'est vrai pour 2006 j'ai décidé
d'arrêter
j'ai décidé d'arrêter des trouées rennie
oui j'ai pris mon sens mouss diouf je
serai prêt 16 mois ce qui pousse les
doigts de leur dit non à français le pc
le pays de moi je suis fan de chou fans
de dorothée
ah oui j'ai pas honte de le dire la
seule fois où je me suis fait [ __ ]
sait si dans une sandwicherie gp un
sandwich avait rien dedans
la force de le pen ces îles à canet il
est trop fort avec un oeil avec laquelle
il voit tout c'est chaud j'ai jamais dit
ça à personne mais mais laurent baffie
qu'un diable un job chez terrain à
servins j'ai été voir tous ces trucs
non parce que les clés d'abonnés les
maudits faut pas y aller subir
merci d'avoir respecté la concession
nombre oui d'où l'importance du slogan
toujours j'aimerais bien avoir une plus
grosse montre parce qu'il n'est pas
thierry tu m'excite quand quand tu dis
moyettes auxerre magnéto
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu